schulschließung immer ausgeschlossen das
kommt nicht mehr hat die politik ja
versprochen aber schulschließungen
kommen eben doch heißen bloß an das
erste bundesländer haben die
weihnachtsferien verlängert heißt
schulen schließen früher brandenburgs
bildungsministerin britta ernst die
ehefrau von altbundeskanzler olaf scholz
die hat das eben gestern verkündet für
brandenburg und in sachsen-anhalt kommt
jetzt dasselbe und wir stellen uns hier
die frage patricia müssen wir familien
müssen wir eltern einen jetzt alle
wieder zittern dass wir wieder in diesen
schulschließung modus kommen ich tue es
auf jeden fall aber wir darüber sprechen
mit lydia rosenfelder es unsere
redakteurin im bild politik ressort dir
du hast auch gestern einmal direkt
nachgehakt nämlich in brandenburg dort
wo wir gestern eben dann die nachricht
gehört haben so die schulen
präsenzunterricht ist ausgesetzt die
weihnachtsferien staaten früher welche
antworten bekommen also wir waren ja
erst mal alle alarmiert vorgezogene
weihnachten das kann kennen wir noch vom
letzten jahr da wurden auch die
weihnachten vorgezogen nur ein paar tage
und daraus wurden dann aber monate und
für bestimmte schulklassen vor allem für
die mittelstufe fast ein halbes jahr
ohne präsenzunterricht also ohne
richtigen unterricht in der schule aber
das gute an deutschland das ist ja in
ein land in dem mit der die bildung in
den ländern entschieden wird also
bildungsföderalismus gilt und da sind
wir zu ganz unterschiedlichen
ergebnissen gekommen als wenn man
nachgefragt haben und viele fanden die
idee mit den vorgezogenen ferien
überhaupt nicht gut zum beispiel sachsen
da sagt uns der kultusminister christian
piwarz von der cdu das verärgert nur die
lehrer und bringt und die eltern und die
schüler das bringt nichts also die
schüler wahrscheinlich nicht aber die er
vor allem die eltern die ihr halt ein
problem haben mit der betreuung und die
halt auch nicht so viel urlaub haben und
nicht auch noch mal extra urlaub nehmen
können und die wollen das definitiv
nicht machen viele andere länder haben
das auch so aber können wir schon mal
ein haken dran machen das ja ganz
wichtig also brand minogue willst jetzt
hast du in sachsen nachgeladen und
sachsen macht zwar alles was dich gerne
schule neben ich hab kein anderes
bundesland bis auf sachsen anhalt die
machen das auch kein anderes bundesland
hat gesagt wir machen das manche haben
sich so ein bisschen gedrückt um die
antwort aber die übergroße mehrheit hat
gesagt das gibt es bei uns nicht und
manche haben auch extra nochmal dazu
gesetzt die schulen bleiben bei uns
offen interessanterweise bayern das ja
gerade auch ein hoch incidents land ist
hat gesagt die schulen bleiben offen das
ist finde ich schon eine gute nachricht
und auch hessen hat ganz klar und ganz
entschieden sagt wir haben den bürgern
versprochen dass die schulen offen
bleiben und das bleibt auch so und dafür
gibt es auch gute gründe denn schulen
sind mit die sichersten orte nirgendwo
wird mehr getestet die impfquote beträgt
in hessen beispielsweise über 95% und
99,9 prozent der schüler die täglich
getestet werden sind werden negativ
getestet also man hat sozusagen eine eng
eine engmaschige kontrolle wie fast in
keinem anderen lebensbereich und
deswegen kommt da aus ganz vielen
ländern klares bekenntnis jahr zur
schule jahr zur offenen schule trotzdem
ist es natürlich immer auch ein problem
wenn man wenn ein land anfängt da so ein
bisschen daran herum zu schrauben da
muss man ganz genau hingucken das dann
nicht doch schulschließungen durch die
hintertür kommen aber alle haben glaube
ich begriffen nicht zuletzt ja auch die
bundeskanzlerin
das ist einfach schulschließungen so wie
bisher nicht mehr geben darf dennoch ist
passiert in brandenburg und du hast auch
mit der frau gesprochen die zuständig
ist für bildung ja auch die ehefrau ist
das zukünftige kanzlers mit britta ernst
wird es begründet mit dem wunsch der
eltern also es gibt auch eltern die sich
wünschen dass ihre kinder nicht mehr zum
präsenzunterricht verpflichtet sind
genau das habe ich ehrlich gesagt aber
auch schon aus anderen ländern gehört
ich telefoniere ja-seite einem jahr
ungefähr fast wöchentlich mit
kultusministerin oder sprechern von
kultusministerien in den ländern und die
haben ja auch früher schon berichtet das
ist manchmal einfacher ist die
anwesenheitspflicht aufzuheben weil man
erstens nicht nur eben die vor
erkrankten kinder mit denen dann die
erlaubnis geben kann einfach zu hause zu
lernen sondern es gibt auch so unter den
eltern auch eine also eine wahnsinnig
gespaltener elternschaft und da gibt es
die einen die machen total druck und
wollen das dass die schulen offen
bleiben und möglichst ohne masken und
dann gibt es noch das gegenteil von
denen die übervorsichtig sind und
totalen druck auf die schulen machen und
die sind meistens so dass mir aus einem
bundesland gesagt die sind meistens an
sich in den gutbürgerlichen vierteln
also da weiß man schon das sind dann die
kinder die eben einfach dann zu hause
lernen die verliert man jetzt nicht
durch das system deswegen es dient dem
schutz frieden und möglicherweise ja ist
das jetzt vielleicht einfach ein guter
kompromiss um durch den winter zu kommen
das ist doch eine wischi waschi lösung
die meisten schulen werden dass doch und
können das doch gar nicht leisten dann
einerseits die klasse zu versorgen und
andererseits noch das homeschooling zu
organisieren da bräuchte man ja
sozusagen die doppelte lehrerschaft das
war doch eigentlich die erfahrung von
allen eltern das funktioniert genau das
müssen sie auch nicht machen also die
lehrer müssen nicht als auch noch das
homeschooling leisten sondern diese
eltern die ihre kinder von der schule
abmelden die müssen eben die das kind zu
hause unterrichten und einfach mit denen
dann zu hause die arbeitsminister machen
was du geht aber auch nur im austausch
mit den lehrern also es fällt natürlich
auch arbeit dann auf die wieder zurück
die müssen ja trotzdem mit
arbeitsmaterialien versorgt werden im
austausch mit den eltern sein das stimmt
so schön ist das nicht dass es auf jeden
fall durch massiven druck entstanden in
sachsen gibt es diese regelung
beispielsweise auch da hat am dsl die
spd darauf gedrängt dass das so gemacht
wird die union die cdu fand das nicht so
gut also es gibt immer verschiedene
konstellationen in den ländern und dann
gibt es keinen der jetzt so was eben
durch und dann ja finde ich es aber es
ist das geringere übel
schauen wir was da noch so kommt der
korona winter so scheint es mir ist noch
lang die die rosenfelder vielen
herzlichen dank für den besuch bei uns